in our dressing room and you took a crap
and left the stench in the room so that
is the whole purpose of why I was a pet
this is my board room it's not a locker
room
Maria you fired that's Maria Kanellis
getting fired from Celebrity Apprentice
in 2010 by the now Republican
presidential nominee Donald Trump
ironically for her locker room talk
Trump deemed offensive et spoke with the
pro wrestler on Tuesday where she opened
up about the firing and Donald's
controversial Trump tape
she told DT quote he fired me for what I
said and what he said was much worse a
70 year old presidential hopeful came
under fire this week after a video was
leaked from 2005 where he was engaging
in a lewd conversation about women with
TV host Billy Bush Trump dismissed the
controversy during the presidential
debate on Sunday this was locker room
talk I'm not proud of it Kanellis feels
strongly about Trump's comments telling
et quote my hope is that he gets fired
as the Republican nominee I don't think
it was locker room talk I think it was
assault you're fired
you